it is genuinely quite difficult to
describe just how cold this cold feels I
think you can imagine what temperatures
of this degrees might feel like until
you actually get here and it really is
different to what you feel that you
could have imagined we're having to be
incredibly careful as a team not
spending more than a few minutes at a
time
um outside not giving too much skin
exposed but I just want to show you this
to show you just a sense of just how
cold it is
um we're gonna just tip a cup of boiling
water into the air and just watch this
that's frozen mid-air and by the time it
hits the ground it's already big clumps
of ice that are all sort of gathering
Gathering there and look this is the
town of Moher it's known as China's
North Pole which is always cold here we
are right up in the very Northern
northernmost part of China right on the
border
um with Russian Siberia this week it has
set records minus 53 degrees which the
local meteorology Department described
as the coldest in the modern history of
China and what's causing it is this very
very cold period area of low pressure
that's been moving south
um from Siberia because some of the wind
systems that would normally keep it up
in the north there have broken down and
but it's worth saying that this extreme
cold event it is matched by an extreme
heat event that this country saw in the
summer in China in 2022 this country saw
historic heat waves historic droughts
lasting a number of months great
portions of the huge Yangtze River
completely dried up officials here
called it one of the most serious events
in China's history so that sense of
extremes of weather many people say of
course of course contribute to by
climate change